[Música]
foi isso
meu Deus do céu
rola meu pai meu deus o que que tu tá
fazendo aí Mariana
em privada se fosse um elevador tu ia
cair dentro do buraco do elevador se
você não tivesse ali me ajuda
toda molhada
a barba de um lado maior que a outra vou
tirar tu também tem um beiço do
periquito que é maior que o outro não
fica falando isso
tá acabando de acordar velho devagar
velho a borboleta se torna borboleta
porque antes disso ela é lagarta
Olha se você não me ama você também fica
fazendo peixe né
chega 4 meses do isolamento social do
Brasil um mês quatro mês daqui a pouco
era um ano daqui a pouco dois anos tu
vai ver
farofa da gqi cancelado tá vendo fumo tá
entrando tá tudo e todos
tá ouvindo eu falar contigo não é
bom dia para você também Edson bom dia
tô aqui olha só o São Paulo sol viver a
pessoa já entra com a cara assim enfiado
no celular Ai meu Deus do céu
foi cancelada a única pessoa que eu vejo
umas coisas e olha lá Whindersson ó O
livro é bom
engraçado é que cada um gosta de um
jeito né tipo o cara fazer um monte de
coisa boa por causa disso né tipo tu
gosta de ler o livro que sou preguiçoso
gosto de assistir as coisas mas saiu um
Show novo dele na Netflix dia 5 agora
vamos assistir comigo sabe que eu gosto
tem que começar a se dar bem Maria nem
tá se separando a pessoa
virar amigo a gente vai ter que dividir
as coisas tem que ter um bom
relacionamento vamos assistir um dente
de separado
[Música]
só uma vezinha
controle também vai tomar café porque
ele é bem ativo aqui nessa casa Né mais
que muita coisa que deveria mas o que
que deveria se não é minha obrigação não
tem nada você é muito baixa cara não tem
nada a ver você comparar o negócio de um
controle com uma testosterona abaixo de
uma pessoa não vei
falar nisso cadê meu outro controle
camuflado
Onde poderia estar na geladeira né que é
o lugarzinho dele Claro tinha que ser
aqui
Pensando bem eu não tenho obrigação de
ficar guardando Não não é meu é teu bota
na geladeira no sofá na cafeteira
pensando bem bota no cu
Já é grudado mesmo bota do teu que pode
a pessoa nascer para perturbar rapaz se
perturbar com qualquer coisa é um
controle que pede é uma briga medonha É
um bom dia que eu não dou porque se eu
dou um bom dia você não responde aí
quando eu sou um monstro vou sair
hipócrita Você Me Transforma num monte
de porta
eu posso provar para você quer ver pau
que tá você é uma hipócrita eu posso
provar para você quer ver ó
isso aqui é um pedaço de bolo Maria só
que é um pedaço de bolo isso aqui não é
isso aqui você deixou isso aqui para não
lavar Porque tem uma carga de preguiça
aí depois bota dentro da geladeira o
negócio Mariana você tem que reaver suas
ações
não fica pela casa espalhado quebrando
um todo dia igual esse controle velho
que já é bem um teste
onde é que tá Aquela minha regata azul
que eu gosto de treinar
nada
tá no guarda-roupa a última vez que eu
vi tava entre o término colete à prova
de bala
achei uma outra que eu tava procurando
mas não tá aqui não Ah então não sei não
ô Edson se eu for aí achar eu vou
esfregar em tua cara
a gaveta de roupa de dormir velho que
tem a ver roupa de dormir eu vou treinar
de noite
com roupa de Missão velho que confunde
Oi filha tudo bem filho
[Música]
carniça Tu é doida é brincando com
comida
[Música]
aqui pensando como é que seria a gente
Nativa ainda desse jeito que a gente tá
sabe o melhor físico
tem que lembrar também nunca pensei que
a gente fosse ficar se aturando porque
está se aturando ainda sendo obrigada a
viver juntos
[Música]
até treinando junto que ainda não vamos
ter briga você vai poder visitar Regina
Quando você quiser
minha filha não minha filha ela sabe
quem é que cuida dela quem ama de
verdade quem da comida você queria
mandar era para fazenda da sua mãe
sabe muito bem que ela acha mais espaço
para correr para ela brincar e ser feliz
duas pessoas conversando calorosamente
aqui depois quer lutar isso não dá certo
velho
[Música]
nesta casa nem junto mais tá separando
está assistindo com esse meu tablet
Opa sala vou dormir lá assistir alguma
parada por lá ficar por lá mesmo tem
mais espaço para mim
[Música]
Deus do céu nem acredito que eu vou
transar sexo
[Música]
Amor
tu ainda vai querer aquela pizza
[Música]
nós não tinha combinado de já que hoje
nós vamos né se divertir a gente já
tacar o pau de uma vez
pedir junto com você
que você gosta muito de sei lá e quando
chegar aí eu não queria eu não queria
quando eu chego também
vai querer azeitona
Aze
itona
vou botar sempre vou aproveitar e se nós
vamos né fazer a parada de chutar o
balde Vamos chutar de uma vez eu pedi
brigadeiro também velho com certeza
eu quero duas pizzas Tá sim
vamos lá então vou finalizar o pedido
hein
posso fazer
[Música]
Mariana [__]
Mariana
[Música]
rapaz eu ia transar do nada
cadê o carregador dessa pega pega
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Tu é doido eu fiquei indignado com
Brasil como é que pode o cabo aí transar
do nada entra na casa do cara mete a
sola vazaram meu olho
para que os cara me cega mas também
Tomara apanhado também para aprender a
bicho
quebrando tudo eu acho que te virar viu
em vez de ficar com conversa besta
Oi
vamos arrumar as coisas aqui de repente
se vier eu vou explodir tudo aqui
[Música]
eu tô falando baixo eu só estou falando
não você que tá gritando cochichando é
diferente
hotel mais tarde ai foi massa hein top
demais
uma rede de tráfico de animais
silvestres libertando as tartaruguinha
esse cabecinha de praia pulando
pequenininha
Como é que como é o nome do hotel
mas tem coisas que vai desgastando né
essas coisas Vai acumulando vai
desgastando perdendo o respeito
E aí já sabe né
Fala a verdade faz tempo que eu tô
pensando que eu queria mesmo
como é que tu me dá uma arma sem falar
vou na mão Presta atenção aí viu tudo é
meu Deus
[Música]
só vai para baixo da égua na mão
parece um convite
estimado casal as instruções aqui
contidas devem ser seguidas a risca não
faça nenhum questionamento e não hesitem
apenas cumpram essas ordens Vocês
assumiram todo o risco e caso faça ao
contrário as orientações que estou dando
para vocês Vocês estão mais do que
convidados para nossa festa observação
faltar não é uma opção
uma ótima recepção espera por vocês
temos encontro marcado em três dias
local Rua das mucuras 007
mas só que a roupa que a gente tem que
usar deve ser Edson Edson
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu boto fé que aquele grandão
[Música]
Afinal o que a gente veio fazer aqui
mesmo
aceitam uma bebida
Não obrigado a gente está bem assim
quer dizer que são de poucos amigos
além de serem muito bons no que fazem Eu
imagino
por isso que levaram a pena em casa mas
vocês são muito bons também mas tinha um
agente especial que ela poderia ter
feito o serviço inteiro mas sei lá
resolveu
poupar a gente porque tudo para nos
matar
vamos ver o que que ela quer com a gente
hoje
essa pilantra aí que interrompeu nossa
[Música]
essa égua se a gente sai vivo dessa a
gente transa
finalmente a gente se encontrou né
ainda dói muito tu não fala não é
aqui quem fala sou eu
como é que tu sabe Ora como é que você
né
a pessoa quando manda em tudo não tá
nervosa Ela come eu conto nervoso
parece que no meio dos lobos é melhor
falar com frases de efeito não é mesmo
quando a menina foi exatamente isso que
eu acabei de perguntar para a senhora
inclusive esses ferimentos parece bem
recentes né
os lobos não falam os lobos aqui é só em
cima das presas a cigarras cantam à
noite né ninguém fala
não fala ele não fala
É eu sei que o casal fosse mais esperto
minha
bebida para mim por favor
morena Essa mulher tá tirando onda com a
tua cara rapaz
porque ela não matou a gente agora eu
vou explicar porque vocês estão aqui
vivos eu tenho uma pergunta e quer uma
resposta
você matou meu marido e agora eu quero
saber por quê
Pode me chamar de Guiomar e você só vai
abrir a boca para falar porque matou meu
marido a gente trabalha junto há anos eu
tenho certeza que o Edson nunca matou
ninguém combate
porque você não deixa ele responder a
pergunta deixa ele responder e por que
vocês vão Cuidar dessa cara toda
arrombada
Mariana não é
a minha conversa é com Edson mas logo
logo você vai entender
[__] que pariu lembrei Edson [__] que
pariu Vacilão né eu matei um cara mesmo
acho que eu matei seu marido eu estava
em uma negociação com a minha antiga VIP
nessa época eu me chamava de um índio eu
já tinha matado várias pessoas e para
mim era fácil matar todos naquela sala
Cláudia minha Vip era uma mulher de
negócios eu gostava de trabalhar para
ela
nunca precisei matar em suas reuniões
não imaginava que naquele dia tudo Iria
mudar
quando eu coloquei a maleta percebi que
um daqueles cabangas cheirava naftalina
fiquei no fundo da sala Pois aquele
cheiro me incomodava um pouco
é claro que Tony gostou do conteúdo da
maleta
ela acertou e por isso me antecipou que
iria acontecer
liguei para o motorista para deixar tudo
preparado
numa negociação como Aquela é sempre bom
conhecer com quem se negocia
ele sabiam muito bem disso e parecia que
minha Vip não estava preparada para a
próxima jogada de Tony
ele teve Audácia de colocar o cachorro
para jogo covarde
Claudia era apaixonada por cachorrinhos
mas a gente já sabia que o Jared era o
cachorro de uma jovem garota que Tony
treinava ele tirou um dos braços dela
Cláudia jamais aceitaria isso
o desgraçado atirou no cachorro na minha
frente ou melhor as minhas costas bem aí
ele arrumou um problema para cabeça com
certeza
[Música]
E aí eu matei ele mas como você matou
ele Ora como
matei com um lápis
toma toma Edson
Você acha que a vida de um cachorro vale
mais do que a vida de um homem mas do
nada cachorro da minha tia quase
arrancou minha perna
Ah mas como é que a culpa pode ser do
cachorro Tu sabe o que que acontece
quando o cachorro é maltratado deixa um
ele 15 dias debaixo de um pé de manga e
o bichinho fica lá no sol na chuva ainda
com fome mas tem cachorro que é otário
viu
filme de guerra que tem cavalo morrendo
por mim eu não assisto você corta meu
coração só os cavalos né
sabe o que acontece com os boi com as
vaca
ele mata para tu comer tipo aqueles boi
lá que corre lá na
Itália eu tenho certeza meu brother
depois dali É churrasco Que tal se o
negócio é até na Espanha toda vida tu
muda de assunto
José Ruela isso que tu é mano
e tu macho qual vida vale mais do mano
do Cachorro e cachorro que merece morrer
não cara
assim de fato Deveras formidável
meu amigo Cruel O cachorro policial
o nome do cachorro quer falar do filme
falou Marley e Eu mas o cachorro
Obrigado querida Afinal o assunto aqui é
o meu marido marido esse que matou um
cachorro hein sempre muito bom lembrar
viu rapaziada matou um cachorro
Tony eu era os mais do que um casal
muito mais
tínhamos nossos momentos de desavença
obviamente
mas nós sempre superarmos o carro
como ele dizia
perdê-lo me causou o maior desfalque
nessa organização ele era o maior homem
em todas as situações e missões do nosso
Império eu carreguei a certeza de que
ninguém nos pararia missões nos quatro
cantos do mundo às vezes junto às vezes
separados
nos separavamos por alguns dias às vezes
por semanas mas depois voltávamos um
para o outro
ele sempre voltava para mim
até que não voltou mais
Eu segui sozinho
eu jamais poderia abandonar tudo que
construímos fora o nome dele que está em
cada coluna dessa organização
então Eu segui Firme nas minhas posições
até finalmente ter esse momento em mãos
momento da Vingança
alguém me deu a vida por algo tão grande
merece descansar em paz eu sou esposa
devo isso a ele olhando nos olhos de seu
assassino
entende o que a senhora queria uma
resposta saber o porquê o seu marido ter
morrido
mas a decisões que a gente toma na vida
leva a gente para os lugares bem
específicos
tanto que tá todo mundo aqui hoje
todo mundo aqui e todo mundo aqui é
igual Todo mundo parecia diferente mas é
tudo farinha do mesmo saco e vai para o
mesmo saco
que a nossa maior certeza nossa maior
dúvida
que é a morte todo mundo aqui vai morrer
ou ela almoça que não vai viver 200 anos
porque é o cara mais rico do mundo vai
morrer também
e a gente não tá acostumado com o fato
de
ter que saber viver sem as pessoas que a
gente ama
eu não amo ela
falando no geral
e a gente deixa de valorizar muita coisa
simples por conta da rotina é tudo vira
rotina da vida
Às vezes a gente deixou uma
privada levantada né uma tampa ele não
bota as coisas no lugar ali deixa um
pedacinho de bolo desse tamanho no prato
para não lavar o prato
mas ainda
É melhor ter tudo isso do que perder
tudo de uma vez né
E o seu marido Ele fez a escolha dele
adianta ele saber das consequências ele
fez a decisão final
nenhuma alma volta de lá dizendo para a
gente juntar mais dinheiro comprar uma
casa
que vai atrás disso a gente tem que
aceitar as consequências
tudo isso foi decisão dele a gente
decidiu estar aqui hoje ninguém Forçou a
gente vê aqui hoje a gente ficou curioso
a gente podia ter tentado fugir não sai
de casa naquele dia ninguém sai de casa
nunca matei ninguém na verdade nunca
matei ninguém querendo toda vez que eu
matei foi porque eu precisei Eu tenho um
cara de uma pessoa que sai de casa para
matar alguém tem nada mãe tu nunca teve
mas aí atirar no cachorro é [__] não
é não hã perdão
comigo não foi assim
eu nunca tive a chance de decidir nada
eu fui treinada desde criança por essa
organização
fui a primeira gente do programa do Tony
ninguém nunca me perguntou se eu queria
ser a gente um assassina
e fazer tudo que eu faço por aqui
passei anos nesse lugar
fiz e foi tudo
menos eu mesma
[Música]
eu começava a ser treinada pelos
melhores agentes dessa organização
e nesse sistema eu cresci
sem vida sem história
sem nada
mas os ensinamentos que eu aprendi foram
muito além das instituição
eu aprendi muito em cada combate
todas as vezes que eu vi e senti meu
oponente
pois isso era o mais próximo que eu tive
de uma relação
porque eu tava sozinha
sempre sozinha
e o único laço que eu tinha
era ele
o Jared
[Música]
todos estão preparados para minha
decisão final
[Música]
era meu
Fala meu Deus eu vi a morte tu viu isso
[Música]
por causa de um cachorro cara
Tá certo não está certo
[Música]
no final das contas a gente não sabia
que iria sobreviver a tudo isso na
verdade a certeza da morte é tão real
que é quase impossível acreditar que
saímos vivos Parece coisa de filme
Talvez o fato de a gente nunca ter
passado tão perto da morte
tenha feito a gente se avaliar como
pessoas como amantes e como amigos ou
não a única dúvida que não temos é que a
gente se ama
e entende que gostar de uma pessoa é
gostar também dos seus defeitos e
entender que a rotina faz parte mesmo
com uma pandemia no meio e os pontos
negativos disso não podem ser a gota
d'água para o fim não isso deve ser o
início de uma nova vida e se você gostou
desse filme deixa o like e manda o link
para os seus amigos
[Música]
Essa daí é a missão mais rápida que a
gente fez viu
eu achei que demorou para quem apanha
demora
É verdade
Nunes meu Deus
cara quase que a gente perde nossa vai
cadê
[Música]
eu não gosto disso não
ó o nome do show já já é chamativo Isso
não é um culto
[Música]
nada a ver nada a ver tudo a ver
tatuagem
[Música]
Eu já falei